hey you guys movie retrospective going
back to the 70s on this one kind of an
underrated film I've had like actually a
couple of requests for this one and I
had seen it when I was a kid and then I
kind of like forgot about it until a few
years back I was watching remember when
they had I don't even remember when this
came out but they had Bravo's you know
hundred scariest movie moments or
something like that and somebody put it
on YouTube and I was watching it and it
had a scene from this like at number 54
55 or something and I was like oh yeah
man I forgot all about that movie so I
decided to do it and funnily enough like
somebody mentioned it in the comments
like just a couple days before we
recorded this so I thought that was kind
of fortuitous this is the 1977 film The
Sentinel
yeah what's weird about this movies
that's almost got an all-star cast this
is like the weather stars
amazing well know some of them before
there were stars and some of you into
like after like something like that into
their careers I mean you got it's like
okay Chris Sarandon is in this who her
fans will recognize from childsplay
Fright Night burgess Meredith is in this
yeah good for walking Christopher Walken
is in this it's very very small role
let's see he was who else is in this
Jeff Goldblum is in this Tom Berenger
Jerry Orbach John Carradine and then
like Ava Gardner is in it
Sylvia miles who actually she had a
couple of Oscar nominations she was in
Midnight Cowboy [ __ ] like that cute
seventies chicks yeah well the funny
thing about this is that the main
actress that's in it christina rains
because she said she looks very much
like Kate Jackson it's not though but um
you're saying that you'd seen her before
so I looked up her page she had actually
she started out as a model like I guess
in New York City and then she did like a
bunch of horror thriller type movies
like in the 70s and 80s she was in the
first Ridley Scott movie the dualists
okay
she was in nightmares from 1983 that
horror anthology which I still want to
do one of these days she did like a [ __ ]
ton of TV she liked Alfred Hitchcock
Presents Murder She Wrote Love Boat
Fantasy Island all that kind of stuff I
remember as a kid just it was probably
like you said love
Fantasy Island yeah she was on tons of
TV and like like thriller-type soon as I
saw her I recognized her buddy know what
her name was
yeah and I couldn't really place her but
she she look back to something off of
Charlie's Angels you know yes she had
that a little more kind of look yeah but
you know you could say they kind of all
look like that then that was like a real
popular look it was yeah that hairstyle
they were all like really really Fantini
and them same [ __ ] bell-bottoms and
the high waisted pants I don't even know
you had to be into coke to be able to
that's what it was like this is very
very unnaturally you had a real [ __ ]
skinny yeah because like I said some of
those pants like I don't even know how
they could for you them you could man
you either had to be real skinny or it
had to be like a Russ Meyers babe that
was just like yeah totally [ __ ]
hourglass with [ __ ] big boobs and a
big booty you know that's work too but
you couldn't have a normal body style
not know where it was one extreme or one
extreme other yeah but yeah so so yeah
she's in it kind of playing the main
role she actually retired from acting in
1991 and became a kidney dialysis nurse
okay so there you go with that now this
was actually directed by Michael Winner
who was directed a lot of [ __ ] he's
British
but probably best known for directing
the first two Deathwish movies now he
actually um co-wrote this with the guy
that wrote the novel whose name was
Jeffrey convence I think the novel came
out in 1974 now this is kind of one of
those satanic occult type movies much
like you could tell that the that the
novel particularly was influenced very
much by Rosemary's Baby and The Exorcist
and all that kind of stuff so this movie
even has some of the same [ __ ] like like
it has a scene at the beginning like
that's at the Vatican or wherever the
hell it's supposed to be that kind of
parallels the scene in Iraq from the
beginning of the Exorcist it has like a
vibe of you know a woman moving into an
apartment building in New York City
where all these like weird people live
that are like seem really weird and like
overly friendly and that type of thing
yeah during this phase in the movie I
was really thinking Rosemary's Baby it
did come across
you know I think this was after
Rosemary's Baby it was Rosemary's Baby
came out almost nine years before this
right so you know that I think there was
definitely some influence there yeah
that kid yeah and you can tell that um
now I heard I'm not sure if this is true
or not but I was reading like
extensively about this movie and about
the the production and everything the
strange thing about this movie is that
it seems like they were trying to go
like a more prestige horror about like
Rosemary's Baby The Exorcist the omen
yeah like that type of stuff so it has
that kind of vibe but then it has like
this really weird like over-the-top gory
can't be kind of thing where they just
put like stuff in there that's just
shocking for the sake of it which is
really good it was yeah it was like a
really interesting juxtaposition so I
can see why like a lot of people that
saw it back in the day cuz I remembered
like a few scenes from it like very
vividly from when I was a kid because I
probably saw it in the early 80s on
cable or whatever and that some of the
scenes like really stuck with me so I
feel like if you saw it back then it was
one that really stuck with you if you
see it now it's like the it's totally
it's very strange it's a very strange
movie but not in a bad way it's it
almost kind of like it has been
experimental yeah it had all of these
kind of you know disparate elements to
it and so it's kind of a weird yeah you
know what you know to kind of note it
kind of struck me as kind of like
Rosemary's Baby and The Changeling which
was kind of like serious yeah serious
[ __ ] movies but then it would have
like so weird gore they look like it
came out of a damn Italian movie yeah
and you're not the first person to say
that yes like I said I heard that this
was actually originally supposed to be
like a more prestige project like I said
directed by Don Siegel who had also done
I mean he's done a [ __ ] ton of stuff but
I think most recently he had done like
the UM the invasion of the body
snatchers and all that from the 70s and
so I think as more people like started
falling away but they still ended up
with this like amazing [ __ ] cast oh I
also forgot to mention beverly d'angelo
very famous from like the national
lampoon's vacation movies she's in this
as a mute ballet dancer who masturbates
in front of someone yeah yeah no reason
and it
just like so like I said it's a very
weird yeah there was a there was a
reason though what they were talking
about is I remember back in those days
they were having these weird like cults
yeah that were supposed to be like
self-help groups and they would [ __ ]
like make people [ __ ] like jerk off
in front of each other to like make them
more comfortable within a cell and other
people and it was like but really what
it was is it was I think was just run by
hugging perverts probably more anything
else but you know they back in the 70s
they had all the damn experimental you
know psychology yeah what and what was
it was like an older like which type
chick and her younger girlfriend were
big into this and if you look at the
older which type chick it's the [ __ ]
gypsy from funhouse yeah like I said
that'd still be a mile she wasn't fond
of stuff I mean she had been like I said
she was nominated for a couple of Oscars
at some point just a dirty old woman you
know what's weird though I think I think
if please forgive me if I'm wrong but
I'm pretty sure that in this movie she
was only 45 years old she looks like she
said which I was like wow she looks a
lot of well people looked a lot older
like they were cuz I was like [ __ ] man
that's like three years younger than me
now yeah and she she looked she always
looked like some dirty old lady that
would you know well that's the part that
she played yeah in every point every
time I've seen her in a movie she's a
dirty old lady the truth well because
okay so the weird thing about this and
it's almost kind of set up because I
like I said I saw it a long time ago I
remember it had something to do with you
know a demonic something or gates of
hell or something like that but I didn't
really remember like all the particulars
so it's almost set up like a murder
mystery kind of you know to me like a
mystery where you know you have
Christina reigns character who is named
Alison and she's a model and she has a
boyfriend who's a lawyer he's played by
a Chris Sarandon I think his name's in
Michael and um you know he wants to
marry her and that you know do the whole
family you know settling down thing and
she's like well she'd had some mental
problems and passed she too had a couple
suicide attempts like there's
there's like a kind of a funny horrific
flashback of like her catching her naked
gross dad like yeah having a threesome
with like these two prostitutes and yeah
it was he was he had all the bases
covered - he had a big fat one and like
hot and like a hot skinny one at the
same time oh yeah full spectrum full
spectrum lechery yeah he's trying to
cover all this yeah so like her dad her
dad dies so that brings up like um you
know all these kind of like things from
our past and like her you know suicide
attempts and everything so she tells him
she's like look I still love you I still
want us to stay together but I need my
own place you know I want to sort my
[ __ ] out before like I can commit to you
and all this other kind of stuff very
very 70s so she finds this amazing
brownstone like an apartment in Brooklyn
Heights and they did actually film it
there so like all the locations and
stuff that is where they say it is I'm
not sure about the inside but um the
outside of the brownstone everything
that actually was in Brooklyn Heights
where they shot it so she finds this
apartment for just like an amazingly low
/ it's like $400 a month which I think
was I mean that was cheap for Brooklyn
Heights even back in 1977 I mean because
it's a massive massive apartment and
it's furnished so she moves in and
immediately she starts meeting these
people in the building first is burgess
Meredith who it's burgess Meredith I
mean he comes across as like he's kind
of like this movie's mrs. castevet
you know what I mean where he's kind of
but he's not quite that obnoxious like
he comes over he's got like a really
cute like black-and-white cat named
Jezebel which should be a red flag
he also has a little bird like a little
canary named Mortimer and riding on his
shoulder and he's all super friendly and
all this other stuff and like it comes
across as an old warlock queen really
what he comes yeah that's what you talk
it's like he's a little intrusive but
like I said he's not he doesn't come
across as sinister necessarily not in
the same way that mrs. castevet comes
across a sinister in Rosemary's Baby
even though he's kind of like the
equivalent so I like dr. Bombay yeah so
as it goes on like she makes friends
with him and then she tries to introduce
herself too you know Sylvia miles in
beverly d'angelo who are portrayed and
like I'll get into this a little bit
later but there are some kind of
baby mmm it's problematic type stuff
that happens like you know just because
it was the 70s you know there because
they're kind of implying that because
these women are lesbians that they're
like debauched or like they they kind of
give that sort of vibe you know what I
mean so the so the two of them like I
said that she goes down to their
apartment to introduce herself and you
know one of them like Sylvie is all like
creepy and then she starts like you know
putting the moves on Beverly D'Angelo
and the Beverly D'Angelo starts like
like masturbating in front of like yeah
yeah she gives herself off in like a few
seconds and I love the way like Alison
the character is just kind of sitting
there going oh yeah like not really sure
where to look and everything it's like
she has coffee what what am i what has
happened when they were just [ __ ] we
just trying to let you know they were
basically just like these perverse
sexual predators yeah which yes so
that's so that's what what I said that's
how you get this kind of Rosemary's Baby
up and then there's like this she's gets
invited to this party at burgess
meredith apartment and it's a birthday
party for his cat which i guess they
were like trying to say it was like
[ __ ] weird and stuff back then but i
was like i don't know that's not that
weird i mean we don't have a birthday
party for our cats but i don't think it
would be seen as quite as strange yeah
back then that would be seen nowadays
yeah it would be seen as like nowadays i
think it would be like a little
eccentric but it wouldn't be like oh my
god there's this like demonic crazy
people or anything like that so he's so
they have the party for the cat and then
and now i'm gonna spoil this so if you
haven't seen it like go watch it now
you know it's streaming on YouTube we
streamed it on Xbox it's I think it's
only $2.99 or three oh yes what seeing
you know it definitely is it's kind of
like a forgotten you don't really hear
it talked about all that much even in
sort of circles of you know demonic type
movies from the 70s even though I think
I can see how people might not like it
because like I said the tone of it is
very strange and it's kind of like
unusual for the time even though it does
have a lot of influences from the other
you know there's other supernatural like
cult movies from that time period if you
liked Rosemary's Baby you'd probably
like
if you if you liked remember the change
link yeah it's the bat like that I just
watched that the other night again on uh
Joe Bob
but yeah so so what you find out and
this is and I had forgotten to
completely forgotten about this
revelation but it's like so she's like
hanging out those weirdos in the
apartment and she goes back to her
realtor who was Ava Gardner and it's
like you know what the hell is the deal
with all these [ __ ] weirdos that live
in this apartment and it's like I keep
hearing somebody upstairs you know in an
apartment that's supposed to be empty
like I can hear like all this metal like
clanging and like my chandeliers going
crazy or whatever and if a gardener says
to her bombshell like I said spoiler
alert there's no one else in the
building except for you and this old
blind priest that lives up on the fifth
floor who you can see like looking out
the window sometimes he's played by John
Carradine but you don't find that out
until later on so like a lot of times
you see him like sitting up there like
staring out of the window and she's like
creeped out by it she's like well if
he's blind like why is he sitting there
at the window like what's he looking at
and then I was sitting there thinking
well maybe it's I mean it's it's good to
look at anywhere else I guess you can't
see anything wherever wherever he looks
but yeah so you find out that there's
nobody else in the building except for
her and this other guy so then she
starts thinking that she's going [ __ ]
crazy right and like the boyfriend now
the interesting thing about the
boyfriend character who's played by
Chris Sarandon now he's into a [ __ ] ton
of movies he was he's done tons of
movies and TV and everything like that
and he's always like really good he was
really good at Fright Night which we
reviewed a while back but um the cool
thing about his character is that you're
never really sure if you can completely
trust him or not because he does seem to
be pretty supportive of Alison and he is
willing to look into these crazy stories
that she's coming up with it's like hey
there's all these people in the building
like she goes into like the realtor
shows her into one of the apartments
that she says she went to the cat party
in and it's completely different like
it's all you know the ruined it's like
there's nothing in this like just old
furniture and none of the furniture is
the same nobody lives there and nobody's
lived there for a very long time clearly
so she's kind of like well you know am I
just going crazy if some is somebody
[ __ ] with me
so the boyfriend does think well maybe
she's nuts because she had like a
history of mental illness but he does
seem to like kind of come forward and
try to investigate to see what's
actually going on to see if there's
actually something going on in that
building that maybe would explain like
this [ __ ] that she's experiencing so you
know as it goes on like I said you know
spoiler you do find out that the
building is actually the it's kind of
like a situated over like the gate to
hell
apparently and so the Sentinel is who is
John Carradine who's been sitting up
there just like trying to keep all the
demons from spilling out on other earth
or whatever and she for whatever reason
Alison is the next one that is chosen as
the next Sentinel so you know she didn't
really have any say in the matter
they just kind of like decided I'm not
sure maybe the book goes into it I
haven't read the book I've heard it's
not very good but you know a lot of
these kind of supernatural occult
thrillers came out back in the 70s when
the wake of like the success and
Rosemary's Baby and The Exorcist and
everything yeah The Omen and and the
omote yes oh this is so this is very
much in line with that but like you said
there's like some really cool I really
like the you know the scenes of just
like you know the the shadow of like
John Carradine like up in the window
like he's always there like looking out
and there's one really great sequence
which was actually the one that was on
the Bravo scariest scenes or whatever
where she goes into this empty apartment
to see what like all this noises and her
[ __ ] dead dad like her naked dead dad
like just kind of like cruises through
the [ __ ] apartment or whatever and
it's like really really freaky like the
way they did it and then there's like
it's weird because like I said it's it's
kind of like you know more of a mystery
it's kind of like kind of low-key it's
kind of you know like the omen or
something but then there's this one
scene where she takes a knife and like
basically like stabs her dad in the face
and it's like this is like some Lucio
Fulci [ __ ] yeah it's just like if she
just like slices his eyeball in half and
like it all squishes out you know nose
on and it's like oh and I we were like
look pretty good holy crap and it's like
you know what I mean it's just like so
that's
mean about this being like good yeah
totally kind of weird it's just like
because but in a way I think that makes
it more effective because it just kind
of comes out of nowhere and you're not
expecting it this is this kind of like
level of gore they don't really do a lot
of that like a lot of really gory kind
of [ __ ] but that was like kind of a
show-stopping
sort of moment and I thought it was kind
of cool that they that they did that but
another thing that I want to say cuz
like I mentioned earlier you know there
was the whole thing about you find out
that all the people that she had seen in
this building um you know the cops and
her boyfriend and stuff are
investigating and they find out they're
like we'll all these people that she's
you know she knew all their names cuz
they introduced themselves and what they
looked like and everything and she item
she's like hey this is them and
everything and it turned out that they
were all dead and that they were all
murderers
so essentially what all these people in
the building were trying to do is trying
to they're demons
and they're trying to like dissuade her
from taking the Sentinel position you
know what I mean so they can kind of
like they want her to like kill herself
or you know do whatever so she can't
take over and so they can like run
around loose so the thing that they do
so like I said these two lesbians or
demons another thing they do at the end
so dick Smith did the effects on this
and you know he's like really famous
makeup artists and everything however
the scene at the end where she's kind of
like in the final struggle and she's
like deciding whether she's gonna take
over as the Sentinel or not they used
some people with special effects makeup
on but just like in Todd Browning's
freaks they used a whole bunch of real
carnival
you know primers and real some of these
dudes are [ __ ] up looking
quote-unquote people with really bad
like facial deformities and stuff like
that which some people thought even back
in the 70s they were like that's a
little much it's like a little
distasteful because you could argue that
yes they did the same thing and freaks
and people flipped out about that but
the thing about Todd Browning's freaks
which came out in 1932 I believe was
that the the freaks in that were
sympathetic I mean they were the good
guys you know the bad guys were like the
normal-looking people in this one
they're kind of like implying that these
are like
means you know what I mean and they're
just like people with really [ __ ] up
like looking facial deformities which I
don't know it bothered me it didn't
bother me like that much but I'm saying
like even back in the seventies because
I read some contemporary reviews of the
movie and even back then they were like
yeah it's a little sketchy man it's like
what just think about what you're saying
but that [ __ ] yeah but you knew he's
portraying them as you know denizens of
Hell right and so yeah so like I said
that is I did look scary though they did
look scary so you know
mission accomplished but yeah so it is a
little problematic and you can say that
you know this is Michael Winner we're
talking about I mean like I said he's
known for the Deathwish movies and you
know he dug but he did a bunch of other
ones too he did he made the big sleep
and I think he made [ __ ] he made the
night comers which was supposed to be
that one with that was um what do you
call it a prequel to turn of the screw
was Oliver Reed in that he did like a
whole bunch of movies with Oliver Reed
anyway so he's like a British filmmaker
and I don't know how what his reputation
is like here but according to most
British film fans that I you know that I
know about or have heard about or have
talked about this movie or talked about
Michael Winner he's kind of seen Michael
Winner is kind of seen in the UK is kind
of like a like a trashy filmmaker or not
not so much trashy it's just like
somebody that's just you know trying to
make a book like he's not real a real
auteur he doesn't really care about the
project or anything he just wants it to
make to make it like really violent a
really shocking or whatever is selling
at that time so he's just like trying to
make a buck off it that's like what I've
heard you know I don't know like I said
I don't know what reputation yeah he's
playing to win yeah in the u.s. I'm like
I said he has made some like
well-regarded movies but so he did get a
lot of criticism for particularly for
that not so much for the lesbians even
though that's kind of weird too but you
know for using you know people with real
facial deformities and saying that these
are essentially demons you know it means
and not for sharing them sympathetically
it's just kind of like just - I didn't
take it then get a shock I mean yeah
it's like you're just saying that demons
can be anything yeah because I mean
because some of the people were normal
looking to be
oh yeah it was you know demons could be
anything they could have any
predilection they could have any
orientation that's all it was
yeah anyone can do it just there were
just too damn lesbian demons that were
trying to tried to rape her in a way
yeah and like I said everyone that's in
there was murderers too I mean like when
they looked up at least the ones that
were at the party I don't know about
like all the people people go yeah
that's essentially what they were and I
think they imply don't think they see
this outright but I think they said they
were implying that burgess meredith was
like the devil because he was kind of
the one that was like you know
corralling all of them and was like in
the front was like trying to get her
like give her the knife and like get her
to kill herself and stuff the
interesting thing about this movie and
like i said i don't know how this
differs from the book but they made like
such a big deal which like i said was
very 70s you know women's lib type of
thing where you know she very much
wanted to like be independent and she
wanted to find herself and stuff just
because she had had so many mental
problems in the past and she wanted to
you know admirably she wanted to be able
to like stand on her own two feet like
before she married this guy and
everything so she wanted her own place
and to sort herself out but then at the
end it seemed like i don't know if the
movie went far enough to say why she had
been chosen specifically because there
was obviously some kind of like weird
supernatural [ __ ] like it was calling
her because ava gardner the real estate
agent I mean she so you know Alison
answers the ad and then Ava Gardner is
like trying to get her in there and it's
like I think that she was like chosen
somehow because as soon as she moved
into the apartment she hadn't started
having like all these weird like
physical [ __ ] happening like she would
start getting dizzy and like having like
weird [ __ ] going on in the apartment and
she was like faint and all this other
kind of crap and then she there was just
really one one really weird scene I
think you were out of the room when this
was on but where she opened up this book
and she was like Rena she's like it's
all in Latin it's all in Latin and her
boyfriend's looking at it going what are
you talking about it's in English and he
and but he did believe her and he was
like write down what it says you know if
you can see it so she starts writing
down all this Latin which is not what it
said and then it ended up that from
being from Paradise Lost and all this
other kind of stuff so then like they
figured out that it was you know gateway
to hell you know abandon all hope ye who
enter here and all that kind of stuff so
but I feel like she didn't really have a
choice in the matter like it was almost
kind of like the the Catholic Church or
this little group or whatever had like
chosen her and there wasn't really
anything I mean she could choose to like
not do it yeah but then all the demons
would escape that's that's a constant
theme and say yes horror I mean in the
legacy the girl that get Susan chosen by
the damned warlock to take to take his
place reminding me of know about this
[ __ ] going on this reminded me of that
that was just a constant theme in the
70s and that is just a plot device
yeah don't read anything into it no I
was what I want what I was saying was
that I wish the movie had gone more into
like why she was chosen particularly no
man just I was we were alive in the 70s
you know I was yeah you know at this
time how what year was this 77 yeah I
was eight years old yeah okay people
didn't think it didn't look in the [ __ ]
that much back they were [ __ ] smoking
dope and they did all kind of [ __ ] ever
it's just they were just movies yeah you
know and not telling you was part of the
movie could people didn't question it
it's just why I was this [ __ ] trip
man that's all it was they went a little
bit into it because I mean I think it
was something to do with her past and
like her suicide attempts and everything
like that because I think that was like
a common thread of all the people that
had been you know sentinels prior to
that and like I said I read like a kind
of a rundown of the novel which I think
goes a little more into why that
specific that might have been in the
movie at one time but they pressed cut
that out just if I could make the movie
shorter the just you know I mean the
thinking of the time was was this kid
movie over with
yeah I mean there was just enough there
to entertain you and to keep you there
in the theater and to buy tickets which
it worked yes you didn't have you didn't
have the modern situation where the
movie is up online and people can watch
it over and over again and people can
review it and analyze it on YouTube and
talk to other yeah just that culture
didn't exist then it was just why I saw
this movie
it was a [ __ ] trip man and that was
it that was it yet as I fly stand it if
and his nose cut off yes I only saw the
thing once there was no VHS really to
speak of her video I know isn't that
funny so this is so you can't you can't
judge these things by modern standards
you went and saw the movie in a theater
it was a one-time experience that was it
you didn't have you didn't have enough
time to look into it yeah you thought
about it for a little while maybe you
went back and saw it again and they made
more money Ching but you know I mean
it's just the audience's at the time
just didn't need the damn questions
answered like I could remember going to
see alien the first a live my dad and I
just [ __ ] blew my [ __ ] mind man
blew everybody's mind there's a lot of
unanswered questions in alien 1 a [ __ ]
ton of them but people really didn't
wander that much about it well yeah but
like I said and you know nowadays that
we have [ __ ] blu-rays that have all
these extra features and all at us
I mean people did talk about I mean
there was still like film criticism and
stuff like that but I think it was a lot
more niche because that was kind of just
mostly the purview of like you know an
intellectual class that like stay and
they were talking to each other mostly
and they were talking to each other but
now it's kind of like it's almost kind
of like become a universal public yeah
like everyone is kind of into doing that
it might be destroying film too because
no matter what you make there's gonna be
somebody on there saying [ __ ] they're
gonna [ __ ] yeah that's true of anything
I mean that's been going on for like
forever even if I mean there's even if
you look at like the novels for example
that are considered like classics
nowadays if you go back and read some of
the reviews of them that came out at the
time the novel came out like in the 17th
or 18th century there are like some
scathing [ __ ] reviews what's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] again so if there's always
gonna be like haters and [ __ ] talkers
and people that like you know think your
stuff is [ __ ] even though like 200 years
from Ally people are still reading it
and everything I was just saying that I
that that's just the only thing that
bothered me about it is like I wish they
would have gone more into like why why
she was chosen specifically and if she
was actually drawn to the place because
I kind of got the impression that she
was drawn to it somehow because she was
always kind of like she was a lapsed
Catholic you know she had been through a
whole bunch of [ __ ] like her family was
[ __ ] up her dad had died
and at one point she did like try to go
back to the church like she was gonna
come back into the arms of the Catholic
Church and everything so maybe she did
have some kind of agency she just wasn't
aware of it got out of what I got out of
it I could kind of remembering the times
a lot of movies just involved a bunch of
[ __ ] like predestiny yeah you had to do
it because you were a Catholic yeah
that's what's that's just how it works
you're a Catholic so you got a wee part
you and so now you just have to like sit
here on the fifth floor of this
brownstone or have we have to be blinded
and you have to take my name and all the
the stars of the movies or the lead
characters so the movies were kind of an
avatar for the [ __ ] person watching
the movie so you know I mean you're a
Catholic and you gotta guard the gates
of hell that's all you need to know and
that's that's probably what it was yeah
like you said it was it's almost like
some kind of like duty yeah like and and
you just had to do it and so like I said
now that I'm thinking about it you know
it was probably I don't know if it was
as you know is them manipulating her as
her being maybe drawn toward this
particularly I think the average person
who watching at the time was probably
you know had a Christian background the
pride weren't very religious so what
what basically what it was is the story
is just like you have a religious
background but you're a backslider so
you got a [ __ ] could actually go
guard the gates of hell yeah for being a
backslider that's yes it's just that
simple that's what all that [ __ ] about
the omen was about that the [ __ ]
Exorcist was about that it was that same
[ __ ] dynamic and the movies this
movie is a movie of the of its time the
other ones that I just mentioned were
better than this movie yes not this is
kind of like your B or C Squad yeah of
seventies but it's still good and it's
just live movie it's got some really
good sequences and it likes visited
creepy this is the one you see after
you've seen those other ones well yeah
obviously everyone should see those you
right um like I said you mentioned the
legacy earlier and this reminded how I'd
like that too um the only other
criticism I would give toward this is
like the editing for it is a little
weird like some of the editing is like
really it seems very um abrupt in some
places like there'll be a conversation
going here and then - it'll be like cut
to something else and it's just I'm sure
it looked like a directorial choice it
was just a little weird but yeah this is
like
said if you're into kind of these you
know religious horror movies like from
the late 60s early 70s and you've seen
all the classics but you haven't seen
this one then I would recommend giving
this one a watch like I said it's it's
got some over the top kind of campy
elements to it you know particularly
when you know she catches her dad with
the prostitutes and you know and there's
a couple moments of like really kind of
like explicit Gore which kind of comes
out of nowhere which I like because I
thought it was like more shocking
because if you do too much gore it's
kind of like people don't like but yeah
so it had some really effective
sequences in it it's kind of like a
really weird story so you know I'm into
70s horror and a couple people have
recommended this so I thought it was
about time we got around to it so check
it out it's streaming on YouTube it's
streaming on Xbox some so I'm sure it's
other places as well but if you haven't
seen it then check it out